netflix just put out this
it's not really a trailer it's just a
clip from a show
uh it was a woman who kind of took over
not a woman actually
a man who now identifies as a woman is a
a writer
and took over the netflix twitter
account for a day
and tweeted out this episode of the
babysitter's club
depicting quote unquote a young trans
girl so the
the babysitter's club has this
it's a scene where there's a young girl
and
this girl's friend or brother or
something is in the hospital
and the person in the hospital is this
little boy who's dressed up like a girl
and the doctors and the nurses come in
and they misgender
the little boy by calling him a boy
have you been giving him fluids if he's
dehydrated we'll need to place an iv
have him change into this i don't want
the blue one
um well i hear someone's not feeling
well
let's take a look at the little man
can i please talk to you two outside
i know that you guys are busy but
as you would see if you looked at her
and not her chart
bailey is not a boy and by treating her
like one you are completely
ignoring who she is you're making her
feel
insignificant and humiliated and that's
not gonna help her feel good
or safe or calm so i'm here on now
please recognize her for who she is
and if at all possible could you find me
a non-blue hospital gown
i apologize i love the doctor's so
terrified at the end i'm sorry yes i'll
go get you a hospital gown
because that's what doctors do doctors
go and get hospital gowns but the
doctor probably should be terrified
because now if you suggest that men are
not really women
and women cannot magically become men
then
you're considered a bigot you'll lose
your job you'll get doxed your family
will be attacked
so probably the the doctor is right to
be fearful
consider the message that this is
sending the person who tweeted this out
a
a writer a trans woman i mean you know a
man
and a former babysitter and
we need to talk about how wonderful this
young this episode is and this depiction
of a young trans person
what's really happening here is that one
of the largest studios in hollywood
in the mainstream media most powerful
culture machine ever devised
is pushing this message that we need to
treat confused children confused little
boys
as if they are girls and vice versa the
implication being by the way
when a confused little boy says he's a
girl
instead of saying no you're not just
like when i said i was batman my mother
said no you're not batman
instead of trying to make the kid
come into closer accordance with reality
you indulge that delusion
and then presumably you'll pump him full
of hormones you'll
fundamentally change his sexual
development this is this is being pushed
already by the
so-called transgenderist advocates
how perverted is that how perverse is
that that you've now got an entire
culture
in which if you do not encourage little
boys
who are confused to become little girls
you're somehow the bad guy
that is some perverse stuff
that is some dark dark stuff
the the villains here are the people
who are pretending to be the wonderful
good compassionate crowd
and the people the doctor who's just
trying to
give the little boy the treatment for
the little boy who's actually trying to
heal somebody
he's supposed to be the victim you know
he's supposed to be the the villain
rather in all of this
a total inversion it's not just
happening in one area or another it's
happening in the whole
culture and if you approach anything any
of this from
the mainstream media to hollywood to the
scientific establishment public health
establishment to the professional race
hustlers to the
the elected politicians who are who are
whining because someone called them a
mean word
in a political argument if you are
taking
any of that at face value if you were
giving any of that the benefit of the
doubt
then you don't see just how upside down
the culture has become
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you